first on CBS this morning the families
of two florida teenagers killed in a car
wreck are now suing after they say their
grief was made even worse by
incompetence fifteen-year-old samara
cooks and eighteen-year-old Delia Gibson
were apparently misidentified after the
crash near Pensacola last July the
mistake was not caught until just before
awake and not until after organs had
been taken from the wrong body Manuel
Bojorquez is in Pensacola Manuel how did
this happen well the families say they
simply are not sure and that's why they
have filed a lawsuit to try to get more
answers the Florida Highway Patrol the
County Medical Examiner's Office and two
funeral homes are listed in the suit
after each family says they almost
buried the wrong person I'm not a piece
of not at peace I'm not at peace I feel
like I haven't had a chance to mourn
it's been nearly eight months since
Ranade cooks lost her only daughter 15
year old Samara the pain only compounded
by what happened when she asked the
funeral home to see her before her wake
that's when I noticed that I was not
somewhere and it wasn't mixed up I was
taking me well maybe that's a chance
that she's still you know a live TV it
was a hope it gave me a little hope it
did the teen was instead
eighteen-year-old Delia Gibson a friend
of Samaras who was killed in the same
crash last July
daliyah's parents Tammy and Demetrius
Gibson claimed the director at another
funeral home tried to switch the bodies
back without their knowing Tracey was
like I need to talk to y'all and then
she called us into the office and told
us that the bodies was switched what was
that like for you this hard drop in
their lawsuits the families allege
Florida Highway Patrol officers
incorrectly tagged the victims at the
crash site that Escambia County 'he's
former medical examiner did not enforce
appropriate policies and procedures and
that the Medical Examiner's Office
extracted several organs from the body
of Samarra cooks who was not an organ
donor both families also claimed the
County Medical Examiner told them it was
against policy to view the bodies and
wasn't until preparations for their
daughter's wakes were underway that the
families discovered the mix-up I don't
sleep I think about what happened or I
try to put the puzzles together it's
just like so you don't have any closure
oh no closure didn't get the job limb
right
in a statement to CBS News the Florida
Highway Patrol said in part due to the
nature of this crash involving multiple
ejections positive identifications at
the scene or not made now these parents
say they won't stop pushing for more
answers I don't want that this never
happens or any other parents don't watch
it no one should go through this the
Florida Highway Patrol said a further
review of the case is ongoing to try to
verify additional information where we
start to the funeral homes but so far
they have not commented and the Medical
Examiner's Office told us quote our
sympathies and support remain with the
families Tony all right Manny thank you
very much it seems like a lack of a
verification process at the beginning is
what got us into this situation so
deeply upsetting for those families oh
you can certainly see why they're not at
peace yeah you'd be haunted by something
like that absolutely all right Manny
thank you very much